[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON CAMMARATA: Hi, Everybody.
My name is Aaron and I'm
going to try and figure out
this on the fly.
Hey there.
That's me.
So I'm a team lead in ATAP.
And I would like to show
you some of the technologies
that we're working on
that apply to games
and get you thinking
about what they
might mean for your designs.
So let's start with
an obvious question.
What's an ATAP?
So that's what it stands for.
The way I like to describe
our little R&D group
is that if you think
of all the projects
that we can work
on in the world,
there are those
that are possible
and those that require bending
the laws of time and space.
So we try not to
work on those, but we
want to stay just as close
inside that bubble as we can.
When we do it well,
we get technologies
like Tango, a 3D sensing
technology for phones
and tablets, which
some of you may already
be playing with
and understanding
how they impact game design.
But I would like
to show you some
of the things we have going
going on back at the lair,
I mean the lab, and we'll
start sort of near term
with Google Spotlight
Stories, and then
move a little bit further out
and show you JacQuard and Soli.
So first things first--
Google Spotlight
Stories is a technology
for interactive
360-degree storytelling.
So what it allows you to do is
create an immersive environment
for your viewers, who
can then use their phone
or device to look around
and control the camera,
and in so doing,
the story reacts
to where they're looking--
maybe opening up Easter
eggs or alternate storylines.
We've worked with some
incredible partners.
Most recently, if any of you
watched the Oscars last night,
you would know that
"Pearl" by Patrick Osborne
was nominated for
Best Animated Short.
So it's starting to get
a lot of recognition
as a really interesting
platform for storytelling.
We also worked with Gracie Films
and we released a spotlight
story Day and Date
with the 600th episode
of "The Simpsons," which
we're very proud of.
So you can download all
of these now for free
and check them out.
The team tells me
that I'm allowed
to say that the toolkit
will be released soon.
So if your design aesthetic
leans towards storytelling,
this is a technology to allow
you to author once and then
publish to multiple platforms.
And so, I guess,
just start thinking
about what that might open
up in terms of your ability
to create very emotional
and emotive experiences.
So we'll let that finish out.
And as you can see, we've done
everything from live action
to hand-drawn and so on.
So it's very powerful.
Next, let's talk about Jacquard.
Jacquard is touchable textiles.
So we've created
a capacitant fiber
that we can weave
into any fabric.
And so, here, you're seeing it
demonstrated inside of denim.
And by connecting it
through the Bluetooth button
on the sleeve there,
we can connect it
to any phone or
Bluetooth device.
Now we can start using
fabric to do things
like swipes and pinches
and holds and so on
and controlling devices and
games through any fabric--
chairs, hats, pants, shirts.
So I want to see somebody make
the third-base coach simulator,
you know, like--
OK, thank you.
That was very kind to laugh at.
OK so the first consumer
product for this
is going to be jackets
by Levi's, which
are coming out later this year.
So keep an eye out and
grab yourself one of those.
And last and certainly
not least, we have Soli.
Soli is millimeter
wave radar, which
can detect very fine gestures
with fingers and hands.
And it's small power
draw and form factor
have allowed us to put
it in objects and devices
as small as a smartwatch, as
you see demonstrated here.
What we did last year is
release some alpha kits to some
of our, sort of, chosen partners
and just let them play with it
and see what they
came back with.
And for those interested,
you can go sign up
for a beta dev
kit, which, again,
will be out later this year.
So let's take a look at two of
the examples that they made.
First, one group did immediately
see the application to gaming
and they made a very
small prototype,
where by detecting
how quickly you're
flicking your fingers
over the sensor,
you can control how
fast the character runs.
And then by moving
your hand up and down,
you can glide the paper
airplane higher or lower.
The one that I found really most
fascinating is this last one.
A group in the UK discovered
that by looking at the radar
returns and analyzing
those shapes,
they could actually
detect what material
was being put on
top of this sensor
with a very high
degree of accuracy.
So now all your
hidden object games
can actually require you to
get up and go find something
made of plastic, for example.
So I ask you to look
beyond what we maybe
are used to in terms
of gaming and start
thinking about how some of
this might create some very
transformative experiences.
So with that, I would
like to introduce Michael,
who will talk about VR and AR.
[MUSIC PLAYING]